c'était l'avocate de Guy Georges celui
que la presse a surnommé le tueur de
l'Est parisien les Français découvrent
avec lui la figure du serial killer une
psychose collective s'empare du pays
c'est dire si l'émotion est grande quand
vous héritez du dossier d'ailleurs
comment on héritez-vous
j'allais dire de manière familiale
puisqu'en fait son avocat à l'époque il
a changé d'avocat plusieurs fois mais
son dernier avocat qui était là depuis
longtemps c'était Alex sursulé Alex sur
celui était mon ancien mari voilà et
quelques temps avant en fait il y avait
eu des
des personnes qui devaient défendre avec
lui qui s'était finalement avait renoncé
donc voilà il m'avait dit il faut
absolument que tu viennes avec moi et
deux mois avant les assises enfin très
peu de temps avant les assises ça c'est
fait voilà est-ce qu'il est venu aussi
chercher la femme derrière la robe parce
que j'imagine que ça n'est pas du tout
anodin d'être une femme dans ce genre
d'affaires
oui oui parce que on a travaillé on
avait travaillé souvent ensemble et ça
m'est arrivé effectivement sur des
affaires de viol d'agression sexuelle
qu'on soit deux un binôme mixte
parce que je pense que surtout quand on
veut plaider un acment quand on veut
contester la culpabilité c'est plus
facile je pense pour une femme de
s'adresser d'abord à une autre femme et
d'entrer dans des détails dirons-nous
techniques sans être intrusive ou
vulgaire grossière voilà pourquoi avoir
accepté cette affaire et surtout comment
l'assume-t-on auprès de ses proches vous
avez dû beaucoup entendre cette phrase
comment peux-tu défendre un homme pareil
j'ai même entendu pourquoi peux-tu
défendre à monstre ouais donc le la
première chose c'est effectivement de
passer la le cap du monde vous essayez
de rappeler que c'est un homme et que
pour vous les monstres n'existe pas il
n'existe que dans les contes n'est-ce
pas oui oui oui ce serait tellement
facile c'est le monstre existait ce
serait tellement on règlerait tellement
de problèmes comme ça mais ce qui est
justement vertigineux c'est de se dire
que
la limite entre l'homme j'allais dire
lambda et l'homme qui va passer à l'acte
qui va basculer dans une criminalité
elle est souvent on voit que c'est très
très fragile enfin c'est c'est pas donc
c'est donc c'est vertigineux donc c'est
inquiétant donc on parle du monstre donc
non et le monstre n'existe pas on défend
des hommes mais bien évidemment ne font
pas les faits défend les hommes à
l'époque vous étiez convaincus de son
innocence c'est à dire que au moment
vous le rencontrer vous ne lui posez pas
même pas la question de savoir s'il est
coupable ou non disons que au moment de
le rencontrer et puis j'ai pas eu
l'occasion de beaucoup parler avec lui
longtemps mais effectivement la
rencontre était essentielle pour
accepter de le défendre de savoir un peu
ce qu'il dégageait qu'il était quelle
était sa position puisque au cours du
dossier il avait varié et dans le
dossier Guy Georges
pendant longtemps il y a eu plusieurs
instructions on a cherché plusieurs
pistes c'était pas évident que ce soit
lui ce qui a fait l'évidence c'était
l'ADN or il se trouve que l'expertise
ADN
en gros on était ni fait ni à faire il y
avait eu un moment donné une faute de
frappe donc on avait dit c'est pas Guy
Georges puis deux ans après on nous dit
finalement c'est lui enfin bon c'est pas
sérieux dont je voulais être certaine
c'est qu'il accepte un autre prélèvement
ADN et qu'on refasse une expertise ADN
si la Cour avait accepté de leur donner
voilà c'était ça mon pied il était
d'accord il était d'accord vous ne
croyez pas au monstre travail ponce mais
faut-il au fond du courage ou une fois
incorrigible en l'être humain pour voir
de la lumière là où chacun justement
voit un monstre
oui je pense qu'il faut avoir la la foi
en l'être humain là croire que quand
tout homme on peut trouver quelque chose
oui oui je crois qu'il faut aimer
justement cette cette recherche
aimer comprendre
et je pense qu'être avocat c'est ça
parce que on dit toujours que pour juger
il faut comprendre et le magistrat je
pense qu'il a besoin de l'avocat comme
interprète comme pour lui donner les
clés parce que c'est pas une audience
c'est rapide nous on côtoie des
individus pendant plusieurs années on
capte des clés on capte donc ça aide à
la défense Jean-Yves Boyard feu
jean-yard maître mot disait que l'avocat
et le frère en humanité de l'accusé
formidable phrase effectivement oui il y
a un lien très fort il faut avoir cette
conviction qu'on est là pour les aider
qu'on est là pour comprendre
[Musique]
mais bon j'ai il m'est arrivé de plaider
dans des affaires de terrorisme un peu
sensible c'était à faire chapeau Bastia
donc très politique très
on est sorti du palais vraiment un peu
poursuivi cours c'est par les partisans
de l'autre camp donc voilà y a-t-il une
fierté justement à aller dans ses
affaires à contre-courant de la pensée
dominante il faut aimer le challenge oui
il faut aimer le faut aimer le combat
et puis
quand ça se passe bien chapeau Backer ça
s'était terminé par un accouchement oui
on est très très content et puis on a le
sentiment de voilà de de participer à
l'oeuvre de justice moi ça fait plus de
40 ans que je fais ce métier mais j'y
crois encore je dis je crois encore au
pouvoir des magistrats quand tout accuse
quelqu'un quand quelqu'un a été accusé
pendant plusieurs années je crois encore
au pouvoir des magistrats et au pouvoir
de de conviction qu'on peut dégager et
pour leur faire dire halte la machine
judiciaire doit s'arrêter à un moment
donné voilà il faut arrêter il faut
libérer voilà quelquefois ça arrive
alors revenons à l'affaire Guy Georges
quels souvenirs gardez-vous de votre
première rencontre au Parlement de la
santé par quoi avez-vous été traversé
lors de cette première rencontre ce que
je voulais avant tout c'était de
rencontrer de rencontrer l'homme de
rencontrer de pas parler du dossier mais
de le rencontrer de voir ce qu'il
dégageait parce que
dans la vie il y a des individus vous
les croisez dans une pièce immédiatement
vous savez que vous avez aucun atome
crochus vous allez même pas pouvoir leur
dire bonjour va être difficile donc si
j'avais eu une telle réaction avec Guy
Georges n'aurait pas pu le défendre ça
aurait été trop hypocrite donc j'avais
besoin de le rencontrer j'avais besoin
qui me parle de sa vie carcérale comment
ça se passait et finalement j'ai
rencontré un homme tout à fait ordinaire
plutôt sympathique
voilà c'est tout c'est tout le problème
de c'est enfin de ces personnalités
clivées comme
le psychiatre un jour il est là
ordinaire avez-vous éprouvé de
l'empathie pour l'homme oui dans la
mesure faut-il en avoir pour bien
défendre faut-il avoir de l'empathie
pour bien défendre je crois oui je pense
que on ne peut pas être indifférent il
faut avoir envie de comprendre il faut
avoir envie de de quelque chose oui
votre compteur Olivia Ronan qui a
défendu celle-là Abdeslam dit qu'elle
n'a pas d'exigence de vérité mais de
sincérité la nuance est importante ils
ont le droit de mentir ils ont droit de
mentir ils ont le droit de mentir même à
leur avocat après le problème est une
question d'efficacité c'est-à-dire que
si la personne vous dit qu'elle n'est
pas coupable et si elle veut obtenir ce
résultat là nous on est tenu de lui
expliquer tout ce qu'il y a dans le
dossier toutes les présomptions tous les
indices tous les éléments à charge de
les discuter on est tenu avec lui de le
challenger d'être de faire l'avocat du
diable voilà
après si la personne vous ment de
manière effrontée etc bon c'est son
choix mais on lui aura dit aussi là ça
va être difficile quand même bien sûr
mais pour nombre d'avocats la défense
prime sur la vérité l'avocat n'a pas
vocation à faire avouer son son client
pas plus qui n'est soumis à ce devoir de
vérité non et puis de toute façon je
veux dire après il va y avoir la vérité
judiciaire mais quand on aborde en
dossier ce que l'on pense réellement de
la culpabilité ou pas moi je considère
que c'est totalement indifférent la
seule chose qu'on doit à notre client
c'est d'avoir extrêmement bien étudié le
dossier de lui en donner une
connaissance parfaite de l'aider à
comprendre et à partir de là de voir ce
qu'il faisable et ce que en plus ce
qu'on se sent capable de défendre aussi
je peux comprendre que peut-être
certaines ne
ne pourrait pas défendre certains points
de vue vous vous étiez convaincus de son
innocence et d'ailleurs vous avez plaidé
le droit c'est pour ça que vous avez
appuyé sur toutes les failles de
l'enquête pour très robot peut
ressemblant absence de pieds égyptiens
erreur de la comparaison des ADN oui
jusqu'à la veille ou l'avant veille de
l'arrestation de Guy Georges il y a des
personnes les soupçons allaient sur
d'autres personnes donc moi j'étais
surtout convaincue qu'il y avait matière
à discuter il y avait des éléments à
plaider à expliquer voilà étant précisé
que le principal c'était bien évidemment
l'ADN mais êtes-vous convaincu à ce
moment-là de son innocence encore
fondamentalement
vous savez
je sais je sais pas si j'étais est-ce
que j'aurais mis ma main au feu est-ce
que j'aurais mis ma main à couper non
j'étais convaincu que oui il y avait du
travail à faire j'étais convaincu qu'on
pouvait défendre détruire un dossier
mais voilà mais encore une fois parce
que ma conviction profonde
n'est pas intéressantes et n'intervient
pas dans ma capacité à défendre
rétrospectivement et si c'était à
refaire est-ce que vous vous soutiendrez
cette ligne de défense très offensive
pour ne pas dire agressive au fond digne
d'un Vergès
oh non pas d'une denvergesse Vergès
avait ce talent de il avait cette
histoire d'abord qui était derrière lui
qui lui permettait de revendiquer et
puis il avait un combat politique lui
qui le conduisait à remettre en cause y
compris le droit de des magistrats de
juger nous on n'était pas là-dedans
j'étais une stratégie la ligne de
défense d'acquittement était oui
blasphématoire par la victime oui mais
parce que il n'a pas été compris à quel
point l'erreur sur l'ADN était
importante en 1995 on arrête qui George
il est d'accord on lui fait un
prélèvement ADN on analyse son ADN on le
décrypte si vous savez c'est une série
de chiffres cette série de chiffres est
comparée à ce qui était dans le dossier
qui était l'ADN du killer et ça n'est
pas la même chose
deux ans après on vient nous dire il y a
une erreur de frappe et là ça match
comment peut-on dans un système
démocratique aussi développé que celui
de la France admettre qu'on puisse
envoyer quelqu'un en prison sur la base
de rapport d'expertise aussi
contradictoires qu'est-ce qui me prouve
qu'en 1995 il y a une erreur de frappe
soit on me donne ce qu'on appelle les
gels qu'on me donne tout mais on ne
vient pas d'octtement avec de beaux
écrans PowerPoint etc devant une cour
d'assises il m'expliquer que tout va
bien ça n'est pas possible donc ça ça
n'a pas été compris ça n'a pas été
compris je crois même par les parties et
puis d'ailleurs il faut quand même voir
qu'en 95 si Guy George VI l'ADN avait
été correctement décrypté qui George
aurait été il était arrêté il aurait été
beaucoup plus tôt maintenu en détention
la responsabilité de l'État bon c'était
plus simple de considérer qu'il y avait
pas de responsabilité du tout et donc
voilà donc si c'était à refaire je
referai exactement la même chose parce
que c'est très très bien la science
c'est très très bien les experts mais
les experts sont faillibles lors du
procès Guy Georges commence par clamer
son innocence mais au cinquième jour le
procès bascule mettre Solange doux
l'avocat de l'une des parties civiles
lui demande si les droitiers ou gaucher
et là brusquement il mime un coup qui
part un geste comme un aveu il se piège
la consternation qu'est-ce que vous
ressentez à ce moment là
le ciel qui tombe sur la tête voilà
ou dans les dans les dessins animés tout
ce qui tout qui s'effondre voilà le mur
de verre qui qui tombe voilà c'était
encore maintenant on sent que c'est un
moment ah oui selon qui a été absolument
formidable ce moment d'assise je pense
restera dans l'histoire des des cours
d'assis ce moment ça pour le coup
c'était un moment de vérité et ce qu'il
y a des formidable c'est que c'était un
moment de vérité quasiment sans parole
il a suffi que dit George fasse ce geste
la mitraille du regard et là tout était
dit un moment d'assise comme il s'en
produirament dans cette salle bondée une
petite voix s'élève
après ces aveux pour dire merci
ah oui ça c'est
c'était
on avait traversé une tempête ça a été
très difficile quand même pendant plus
de 10 jours et puis Guy Georges avait
répondu oui à toutes les questions qui
lui avait été posées par Alex sur sullet
et on attend entendu cette mère de
victime dire merci et là c'était un
moment voilà de très grands humanité de
de réconciliation c'est à dire que on
était plus dans le monde
voilà alors je vous dis tout de suite ça
n'a pas duré parce que la colère des des
parties civils à très vite rebondi mais
il y a eu voilà un moment de
réconciliation mais avant ce moment de
réconciliation il y a donc ce geste
il se piège à cet instant précis
le monde vous tombe sur la tête est-ce
que vous le poussez à avouer non on est
saisi mais tout tout va très vite et il
faut on essaie d'avocat il nous a
toujours dit qu'il n'était pas lui donc
il faut réagir il faut donc là tout de
suite je lui pose une question en lui
disant mais qu'avez-vous vous dire parce
que il aurait étant donné qu'il avait
déjà été condamné pour une agression
avec un couteau il aurait très bien pu
dire ben je n'ai fait que refaire le
geste que j'ai fait pour lequel j'ai
déjà été condamné
ça n'a pas été ça puisque en fait je
pense qu'il était parti ailleurs il
était il était parti dans dans son monde
de violence et voilà il était plus
capable de raisonner et
ni de se défendre et donc après il a
refusé de répondre il était encore plus
braqué donc voilà on était encore plus
dans de la culpabilité évidente et c'est
vrai qu'après l'audience il y a eu des
suspensions et on s'est rendu compte
avec Alex ursulay que bon bah voilà on
était au bout du chemin il fallait qu'il
avoue et qu'est-ce qu'il accuse à la
vérité une confrontation avec l'une de
des victimes rescapées c'est à ce
moment-là disons que on savait très bien
que cette victime allait être interrogée
s'il avait quelque chose à dire il
fallait qu'il le dise avant donc en fait
juste avant l'entrée d'Élisabeth Ortega
il a il a avoué de votre côté vous vous
fissurez en pleine audience vous fondez
en larmes qu'est-ce qui vous a boule
français à ce point
pour craquer
alors c'est rare ça aussi c'est un
moment d'assise rare ouais c'est à côté
un peu sans doute un peu ridicule de
mais en vos mains oui en fait il y avait
il y a eu une
il y a eu ce moment donc on voyait que
Guy Georges
basculé avait basculé et la soeur d'une
des victimes est venue témoigner et là
vraiment supplié de dire ce qui s'était
passé et cette jeune fille parce que
c'était une jeune femme jeune fille à
l'époque était absolument poignante elle
a eu une façon de se tenir à la barre
danser presque enfin c'était
voilà et là les 10 jours d'audience
l'attention etc voilà j'étais
complètement envahi par l'émotion ce
dossier Guy George c'est quand même
c'est c'est de la douleur c'est du
réfléchi et y compris pour lui je
l’inclus là-dedans parce que il aurait
pu avoir une vie différente il aurait dû
avoir une vie différente vous vous êtes
identifié ces victimes non parce qu'elle
était plus jeune mais
disons j'étais solidaire je pense de de
la douleur de toutes ces familles quoi
il y a un moment donné voilà on a
surtout à partir du moment où il avoue
le combat est terminé donc on est envahi
par
l'émotion par l'émotion et par leur
douleur c'est l'arme direz-vous c'est
comme si d'un coup d'autres comprenait
que l'on peut défendre tout en entendant
la douleur de l'autre il y a contenu
dans ce moment mon métier tout entier
on est du côté et puis c'est vrai que
cette cour d'assises ont dû toujours
qu'elle est très grande mais on n'est
pas si éloigné des des victimes de leurs
avocats donc on prend dans la première
partie quand on plaidait l'acquittement
on a pris tout toute leur colère toute
leur agressions de venir et c'est normal
on est là on est on sert un peu de
bouclier à l'égard de la personne qu'on
défend voilà et puis après bon ben on
ressent aussi leur douleur on peut on
peut être les deux
on n'est pas quoi en fait on n'est pas
indifférent on n'est pas on n'est pas
des robots alors vous n'êtes pas du tout
un robot le président décrète une
suspension d'audience vous retrouvez Guy
Georges dans une pièce à l'arrière du
prétoire et là pour la première fois
vous avez face à vous quelqu'un d'autre
oui
la première fois vous avez peur
oui j'ai
il était vraiment hors de lui il était
terriblement tendu il avait même changé
de son regard était différent son
physique était son physique était
différent et on avait le sentiment qui
qu'il était prêt à exploser les
gendarmes l'ont compris parce que
d'habitude il nous laisse tranquille
pour discuter et là il y en a un qui est
venu s'asseoir à côté de moi juste à
côté de Guy Georges et j'ai pas pu
vraiment parler avec lui j'ai essayé de
le détendre mais j'avais le sentiment
voilà qu'il allait attraper le gendarme
moi enfin c'était pas identifié c'était
aveugle mais il n'était qu'une boule de
violence mais vous êtes resté à ses
côtés
quand même
les psychiatres qui se sont succédés à
la barre sont tous arrivés à la même
conclusion Guy Georges n'est pas fou il
est conscient donc pénalement
responsable de ces actes bref il a le
profil du monstre froid indéfendable aux
yeux de beaucoup de nos concitoyens
vous savez je veux bien croire c'est
toute la le paradoxe de ces analyses
c'est-à-dire on nous dit c'est un
psychopathe donc un psychopathe c'est
quand même une déviance c'est quand même
une pathologie mais il n'est pas malade
il les reçoit de toute façon Guy George
ne voulait absolument pas se considérer
comme quelqu'un d'irresponsable aller en
hôpital psychiatrique voilà donc c'était
pas le sujet
peut-être parce qu'il considérait qu'il
ne l'était pas et que il était bien dans
90% des cas et
en plus c'était il avait passé déjà plus
de 20 ans de sa vie en détention on est
tension il est emprisonnier model il a
une vie
carcérale mais une vie carcérale qui se
passe bien sans
incidents sont quasiment aucun incident
aujourd'hui il serait fondé à demander
ses libération il pourrait théoriquement
sortir de prison
théoriquement il faudrait qu'il y ait
des des analyses encore une fois des
expertises psychiatriques qui qui se
prononcent ce qu'il y ait des magistrats
qui veulent bien le sortir qu'il est un
projet de vie
je pense que tout ça pour l'instant on
n'y est pas quel lien avez-vous gardé
avec Guy Georges
je vais dire quasiment aucun et puis
je pense que tout ça c'est voilà ça
c'est sa vie aujourd'hui et il a droit
j'allais dire à ce qu'on en parle pas
voilà il est détenu
vous resterez à jamais comme l'avocate
de Guy Georges vous avez été immortalis
sur grand écran en la personne de
Nathalie Baye mais il y a eu aussi des
revers à cette affaire un jour lors d'un
procès vous plaidiez l'acquittement
l'une des parties civiles a rappelé que
vous étiez l'avocat de Dijon ça c'est un
coup bas oui c'est
un combat mais c'est ça c'est régulier
c'est à dire qu'effectivement dès que
souvent ça met ça met on me le renvoie
on me le renvoie à la figure pour
expliquer au magistrat à combien je suis
épouvantable je pense que les magistrats
voilà ça sont connaissent le métier
d'avocat ils sont assez indifférents
assez pique mais très réponses y a-t-il
quelque chose de philosophiquement
essentiel à défendre ces hommes là c'est
cette défense là qui donne finalement
plus que jamais de corps à votre serment
d'avocat
oui
François Gibeau qui était un avocat
connu que que j'aime beaucoup m'avait
toujours dit les assis c'est la vérité
du métier et c'est vrai que moi j'ai
commencé en faisant que de droits des
affaires donc vous voyez j'ai un
parcours très très atypique pour venir
ici et ce qui est ce qui est important
et ce qui je l'ai dit encore plus plus
important peut-être aujourd'hui c'est
parce que
on est profondément attaché à la
présomption d'innocence et ce qu'il faut
envers et contre tout défendre c'est
cette présomption d'innocence qui
aujourd'hui ne semble plus aussi
évidente il faut juger les gens sur ce
qu'ils ont fait et non sur la crainte
qui nous inspire faisait remarquer un
avocat de djihadiste est-ce que la
justice peut vraiment aujourd'hui se
prévaloir de cela alors nous parlons
Frédéric ponce
elle devrait quel condamne pour punir ou
pour protéger la société
l'accusation dans les procès est porté
par le ministère public et le ministère
public il vocation justement à défendre
la société et à la protéger parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre que on parle
beaucoup des parties civils et qui sont
là dans les procès mais elle elle
demande la réparation de leur dommage le
ministère public lui il défend la
société donc il va demander une peine
parce que il y a eu une infraction mais
cette peine il l'a demandé aussi pour
protéger la société parce que ça il faut
que la peine est elle est en effet
dissuasif sur les autres bien sûr l'un à
sinon ce serait l'anarchiste si tout le
monde ne respecte si personne ne
respectait la loi les juges tôt pour ce
qu'ils ont fait ou pour la crainte qui
nous inspire
on doit les juger pour ce qu'ils ont
fait effectivement il faut se garder du
procès d'intention mais c'est vrai que
les incriminations nouvelles qui ont été
mises en œuvre avec le terrorisme
notamment les associations de
malfaiteurs associations de malfaiteurs
des fins de terrorisme ou association de
malfaiteurs ce sont des infractions ce
qu'on appelle des infractions balai
malheureusement permettent de de prendre
d'un leur mailles des personnes à qui on
va dire bon ben finalement vous avez
pris un café avec un tel vous auriez dû
savoir qu'il avait l'intention de poser
une bombe ou de faire ceci ou de faire
cela et là
oui la démocratie est en danger le
terrorisme n'a pas fait que mettre notre
démocratie en danger en posant des bons
et autour il le met en danger parce que
les le besoin des parlementaires de
rassurer leurs électeurs en leur donnant
plus de sécurité c'est de leur faire
plaisir en votant des lois qui ne
respect faut pas les principes de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
encore une fois en France pour nous
protéger heureusement qu'il y a la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme alors
comme aujourd'hui la parole est à la
défense je vous laisse le mot de la fin
le mot de la fin je voudrais l'adresser
aussi au magistrats parce que dans ces
temps on a beaucoup parlé des
difficultés à vos cas magistrats je les
déplore parce que ça fait j'ai connu des
périodes où on pouvait parler avec des
magistrats où on pouvait faire œuvre de
justice ensemble aujourd'hui c'est de
plus en plus difficile je pense que
c'est de plus en plus difficile non pas
tant parce qu'ils ont changé mais parce
qu'effectivement ils n'ont pas les
moyens de correctement et j'allais dire
humainement faire leur travail et de
prendre le temps qu'il faut pour les
affaires et de prendre le temps de nous
entendre et aujourd'hui quand on
m'empêche de parler à un magistrat et on
me répond il travaille mais je viens pas
pour le déranger je viens pour
travailler avec lui
et je regrette que voilà ce lien se soit
délité merci avec vous merci merci à
vous aussi